let me start by saying it has been
almost 10 years since I think I
interviewed you on the set of Zombieland
and I think that you landed on your feet
are you gonna come back for Zombieland
too if they invite me yes us I think it
would be full circle because 2 months
we're starting yeah Ruben said that
they're filming again in Atlanta mm-hmm
I was like ok so it's been 10 years and
you can see how the restaurants have
changed it's perfect right so excited
right let me switch gears completely and
say how much I effin loved this movie
and one of the best of the year so so
good thank you
I mean I don't know why I'm saying thank
you I didn't order thank you so much I
created the whole thing
you're pretty good thanks um but I loved
the cinematography yeah I think Robbie
and Jurgis did a phenomenal job that the
use of lenses the fish lens totally the
way he shot it yeah or they shot it
could you sort of talk about the
cinematography and working with Robbie
and your toes on that ok so that was my
absolute favorite thing to watch and
learn every day because it was for the
most part it was natural light and at
night I mean the light meter was that
like a 1.8 it was so dark with the
candlelight and I know they had to
change some of it in the DI afterwards
but it was just amazing to see like even
at night they're gonna light it entirely
by candlelight and these the composition
of the shots to watching Jurgis because
he has sort of like an idea in his head
storyboard wise with what it'll look
like and then he throws all of it out
and just kind of on the day feels out
what it should look like and then it
turns into these beautifully composed
shots it was it was incredible and also
I don't know if you noticed this but he
he gave each character each woman a
different size for some of their
close-ups did you notice I didn't notice
that but I I'm gonna be watching it it
was like everyone had their own lens in
moments it was really fascinating it's
just he's so visual and he's always
carrying a camera around so he's always
looking at the world through a lens and
Robbie is just you know genius so it was
pretty awesome it's stunning just for
the cinematography alone yeah
performances are amazing but
cinematography is like crazy it's insane
yeah you get offered a lot of cool
projects you've worked you've been very
very fortunate when you got the script
for this was it an immediate like oh I'm
doing this oh yeah yeah absolutely and I
had to audition for this still but I
read the script and was totally blown
away I mean all three of these
characters are just any of these would
be a dream to play so um yeah dude what
was the last time you auditioned before
this one had it been a while um I'm
trying to think because I find that
because you I auditioned for cabaret at
a cavalry on stage I it's not it's
different than the auditions that I was
doing when I first moved to LA and was
like going on okay it's kind of like
okay we've seen you do stuff before but
we need to hear you sing or we need to
hear your accent or you know it's that
kind of thing right and I know I have to
go but just real quick sitting down with
your ghosts obviously you must have seen
his work and been a fan yeah so what is
it like for you even though you've done
all these really cool things sitting
with the filmmaker you really want to
work with and you know what I mean yeah
I because I all I had seen was dogtooth
before I met him because I met him in
the summer of 2015 so the lobster didn't
come out yet and he hadn't even made
sacred deer yet so I was kind of like oh
this guy's gonna be insane like he's
gonna be absolutely nuts and I went to
sit down for lunch with her and I was
like he's so normal and nice and funny
what the hell it's like all of his
darkness comes out through his art so
I'm felt really comfortable around him
right away but I really did think I was
meeting a bit of a psychopath and it
turns out he's not completely there you
go
I say again one of the best of the year
thank you so much thank you
you